And the sons of Noah,
they went forth of the Ark were shem and
ham and Japheth and ham is the father of
Canaan.
These are the three sons of Noah and of
them was the whole Earth overspread and
no began to be a hud.
Husbands,
men,
and he planted a vineyard and he drank
of the wine and was drunk,
and he was uncovered within his tent and
Ham.
The father of Canaan saw the nakedness
of his father and told his two brethren
without and Shem and Japheth took a
garment and laid upon both their
shoulders and went backward and covered
the nakedness of their father.
And their faces were backward and they
saw not their father's nakedness.
And Noah awoke from his wine and knew
what his younger son had done unto him.
And he said,
curse it to be Canaan.
A servant of servants,
shall he be unto his brethren.
And he said,
blessed shall be the Lord God of Sham
and Canaan shall be his servant.
And God enlarge Japheth.
And he shall dwell in the tents of Shem
and Canaan shall be his servant.
And Noah lived after the flood,
350 years and all the days of Noah were
950 years and he died
and the whole earth was of one language
and of one speech.
Okay.
So I remember thinking about this story,
it's got to be 30 years ago
and I think the meaning of the story
stood out for me.
Sometimes when you read complicated
materials,
sometimes a piece of it will stand out.
It's for some reason like it glitters.
I suppose that might be one way of
thinking about it.
It's you're in sync with it and you can
understand what it means.
I've really experienced that reading the
Tao Te Ching,
which is document I would really like to
do a lecture on at some point because
some of the verses I don't understand,
but others stand right out and I can
understand them.
And I think I understood what this part
of the story of no amount.
And I think it means,
you know,
we talked a little bit about what
nakedness meant in the story of Adam and
eve.
And the idea essentially was that to
know yourself naked is to become aware
of your vulnerability,
the physical,
your physical boundaries in time and
space,
and your,
your,
your physiological,
your fundamental physiological
insufficiencies as they make might be
judged by others.
So there's biological insufficiency that
sort of built into you because you're a
fragile mortal,
vulnerable half insane creature and,
and that's,
that's just an existential truth.
And then of course,
even merely as a human being,
even with all those faults,
there are faults that you have that are
particular to you that might be judged
harshly by the group while might be,
we'll definitely be judged harshly by
the group.
And so to become aware of your nakedness
is to become self conscious and,
and to,
to know your limits and to know your
vulnerability.
And that's what is revealed to when he
comes across his father naked.
It's.
So the question is what does it mean to
see your father naked?
And it seems to me,
and especially in an inappropriate
manner like this,
it,
it's,
it's as if ham,
he does the same thing that happens in
the Mesopotamian creation myth when when
timeout an absolute give rise to the
first God's there,
they're the father of the eventual daddy
of redemption,
Marduk there are very careless and noisy
and the kill app suit their father and
attempt to inhabit his corpse.
And that makes timeout enraged.
And so she bursts forth from the
darkness to do the men.
It's like a precursor to the flood story
or an analog to the flood story.
And I see the same thing happening here
with him is that he's,
he's insufficiently respectful of his
father.
And,
and the question is exactly what does
the father represent?
And you can say,
well there's,
there's,
there's the father that you have and
that's a human being.
That's,
that's a man like other men,
a man among men.
But then there's the farther as such.
And that's the spirit of the father.
And in so far as you have a father,
you have both at the same time.
You have the personal father that's a
man among other men,
just like anyone out there,
his father,
but in so far as that man is your
father,
that means that he's something different
than just another person and what he is
is the incarnation of the spirit of the
father and to see that,
to take it to what to disrespect that
carelessly,
maybe even like no,
it makes a mistake,
right?
He produces wine and gets himself drunk
and you might say,
well,
you know,
if he's sprawled out there for everyone
to see,
it's hardly hams fault if he stumbles
across him,
but the book is laying out a danger and
the danger is that,
well,
maybe you catch your father at his most
vulnerable moment and if you're
disrespectful,
then you transgress against the spirit
of the father and if you transgress
against the spirit of father and lose
the spirit of the father and lose
respect for the spirit of the father,
then that is likely to transform you
into a slave.
That's a very interesting idea and I
think it's particularly interesting.
Maybe not particularly interesting,
but it's.
It's particularly Germane.
I think to our current cultural
situation,
because I think that were pushed
constantly to see the nakedness of our
father,
so to speak,
because of the intense criticism that's
directed towards our culture and the
patriarchal culture,
so to speak.
We're constantly exposing its weaknesses
and vulnerabilities and let's say
nakedness and there's nothing wrong with
criticism,
but the thing about criticism is the
purpose of criticism is to separate
wheat from the chaff.
It's not the burn everything to the
ground,
right?
It's to say,
well,
we're going to carefully look at this.
We're going to carefully differentiate.
We're going to keep what's good and
we're going to move away from what's
bad,
but the point of the criticism isn't to
identify everything is bad.
It's two separate.
What's good from what's bad so that you
can retain what's good and move towards
it and to be careless at that is deadly
because you're inhabited by the spirit
of the father.
Right?
In so far as you're a cultural
construction,
which of course is something that the.
The postmodern neo Marxist sort
absolutely emphatic about.
You're a cultural construction in so far
as you're a cultural construction than
your inhabited by the spirit of the
father,
and to be disrespectful towards that
means to undermine the very structure
that makes you not all of what you are.
Certainly certainly not all of what you
are,
but a good portion of what you are in so
far as you're a socialized cultural
entity and if you pull out,
if you pull the foundation out from
underneath that,
what do you have left?
You can hardly manage on your own.
You know,
it's just not possible.
You're a cultural creation and so hamm
makes this desperate error and is
careless about exposing himself to the
vulnerability of his father.
Something like that.
He does it without sufficient respect
and the judgment is that not only will
he be a slave,
but so will all of his descendants and
these contrasted with the other two sons
who I suppose are willing to give their
father the benefit of the doubt.
Something like that.
And so when they see him in a
compromising position,
they handle it with respect and,
and,
and don't capitalize on it.
And maybe that makes them strong,
that's what it seems to me.
And so I think that's what that story
means.
It has something to do with respect,
you know,
and the funny thing about having respect
for your culture,
and I suppose that's partly why I'm
doing the biblical stories is because
they're part of,
they're part of my culture.
They're part of our culture perhaps,
but they're certainly part of my culture
and it seems to me that
it's worthwhile to treat that with
respect to see what you can glean from
it and,
and not kick it when it's down,
let's say.
So.
And so that's how the story of Noah
ends,
you know.
And the thing too is Noah is actually a
pretty decent incarnation of the spirit
of the father.
That which I suppose is one of the
things that makes Hams misstep more
egregious is that,
I mean,
no,
I just built an ark and got everybody
through the flood.
Man,
you know,
it's not so bad in.
So maybe the fact that he happened to
drink too much wine one day wasn't
enough to justify humiliating him.
And you know,
I don't think it's pushing the limits of
symbolic interpretation to note on a
daily basis that were all contained in
an arc.
Right?
And that's the arc that you can think
about that as the arc that's been
bequeathed to us by our forefathers.
That's the tremendous infrastructure
that we inhabit,
that we take for granted because it
works so well that protects us from
things that we can't even imagine.
And we don't have to imagine because
we're so well protected.
And so one of the things that's really
struck me hard,
I would say about the disintegration and
corruption of the universities is the
absolute in gratitude that goes along
with that.
You know,
criticism as I said,
is a fine thing if it's done in the
spirit in a proper spirit and that's the
spirit of separating the wheat from the
chaff.
But it needs to be accompanied by
gratitude.
And it does seem to me that anyone who
lives in in the west,
in the western culture at this time,
in history and in this place and who
isn't similar [inaudible] grateful for
that is,
is,
is half blind at least because it's
never been better than this.
And it could be so much worse.
And it's highly likely that it will be
so much worse.
Because for most of human history,
so much worse is the norm.